mein name ist luca meine lieben freunde
hier sitzt schon dass ich ihr sitzt
schon ich verstehe ihr seht schon dass
sich immer wieder sitze und das zeigt
natürlich selbstverständlich dass ich
mal wieder auf tour motto händel
reagiere
in meiner letzten tour zu händel
reaction haben wir nach dem mitternachts
gespräch zwischen sommer und ronda
pausiert von daher schauen wir jetzt mal
weiter wie es weitergeht ich habe sechs
riesen verloren sondern hat auch den
anderen blöd kann
du hast den ärger selbst verschuldet die
ganze zeit also für den neuen touareg
sions das hier ist francesca und sie mit
herum gelegt das hat die ganzen truppe
dann 3000 dollar gekostet und dann waren
alle natürlich sauer auf sie
dann hat sie als trotzreaktion mit jedem
noch umgelegt das ist haley wenn ich
einer von den anderen leuten da wäre ich
würde euch komplett ins meer schmeißen
wir wissen wurde uns geld jemand hier
sagt nicht die wahrheit und ich will da
raus wer das ist ist also klar dass
jesus wie der sie hat wirklich aus wie
jesus vorher weiß man eigentlich wie
jesus aussah
gab es da keine
es tut einfach für ihn können wir
ausschließen ich war es nicht okay ich
hatte bisher mit keinem nicht mein
gespräch ich weiß auch nicht
ich will ihm glauben als sie waren
nachts im bad nicht aus das ist so krass
dass die zuschauer also wir schon wissen
wer es war und jetzt die herausfinden
wer das war
ich hätte wirklich nicht in einer ersten
reaktion auf tour zu ende gedacht dass
die serie mich mal so catchen wertfreien
traurig alles würde ich wie lautstark
haley sich geäußert
man weiß ja wenn francesca flüstert und
hayley ganz laut ist dann lügen die wow
der wahltag also wirklich ich verstehe
nicht warum die das gemacht haben weil
die haben sich selbst ja auch geld
gekostet
nicht nur den anderen also es macht
wirklich vorn und hinten leider absolut
keinen sinn francesca und hält die
francesca halsall wenn wir darüber reden
möchtest kannst du gerne ich tippe auf
helle und francesca auch sagen hat ist
das kreuz wirklich an den nagel hängen
und volker koepp werden wie der hat echt
wie jesus behandelt wird und die
verwendung ist so stark ich kriege euch
dran und finde heraus wer von euch
halunken zu geil für dieses spiel ist
okay
das ist er der böse jesus gerade die
freuen sich wieder an oder wie und was
willst du privat fühlt sie dadurch
leider fühlt sich verständlicherweise
hatte ich die letzten tage eher negative
gefühle für wurde viel gesagt und getan
ja
unter anderem zwischen dir und hayley na
wenn du mal mit dem anderen was tun
willst
auch wenn wir uns auf augenhöhe
unterhalten werden wir uns nicht einig
ich bin 198 und du nur 150
[Musik]
harry
das
dieser typ flöten aber er steckt ab
jetzt in der kompression also francesca
ich hab ja auch nicht so hast du noch
gefühle für mich direkt raus alter ich
hatte hatte hatte
hatte
es ist aber gut die sind nicht mehr da
da kann ich ja noch platz für neue
gefühle für eine neue person blöd es
nicht ja ich es geht ein summen das ging
harry
nimm dein rugby und g rugby spielen
vielleicht haben wir noch mal von vorn
treffen wir uns zum ersten mal werden
uns langsam gehen wir können uns auch
zum ersten mal treffen und langsam harry
hat das in der ersten folge so krass
laut gesagt von wegen ich rufe immer
wenn ich mittels kennenlernen rufe ich
einfach irgendwie ein lautes wort um wie
beispielsweise rugby und jetzt noch kein
mal gemacht
ich wusste frank schäffler und ich
werden diesen konflikt lösen sondern
echt großes glück denn ich bin der
witzigste typ der welt
[Musik]
das könnte hält leider wirklich ob ich
sage ihnen so davis
ich glaube es ist meine aufgabe ans
licht zu bringen in dessen keller ein
leichensack mit 3000 dollar lag
ich finde so lies wie jeder einfach
schon seine bestimmung hat in dieser
serie
es gibt halt so diese dummen leute das
ist beispielsweise die lampe oder auch
harry will ich dazu zählt dann gibst du
die unruhestifter als und so von
chefscout haley dann gibt es halt jesus
der will alles klären
da gibt es schon ein brauner die machen
wir sie ihr eigenes ding und sind ein
bisschen emotion
ich finds krass ich finde es wirklich
krass am krassesten ist allerdings
dieses neu verlieben - das ist die eine
partie chloride und will auf decken wäre
der gruppe in den rücken gefallen ist
okay okay okay es geht hier um
ehrlichkeit ja
da haben wir direkt die richtige person
im bild die welt kommt sowieso an
schlecht und dann steht er deutlich
schlechter da
predigt jesus ja denke ich mir auch
ziemlich abstoßen ich werde überhaupt
nichts zu geben
sorry du model dass ihr euch mitten in
der nacht allein raus schlecht es nicht
cool
er spielt mit dem feuer und auch dass
ihr euch nicht verbrennt und ich frage
mich schon was ihr da angestellt haben
könnte
die kameras müssen wir bescheid
die wand und das war echt eine krasse
situation die waren der kurzer vorgaben
dann gesagt nee für die gruppe wir
machen es nicht also respekt aber kurz
alle klatschen mittel zu hause respekt
am rande
man kann keinen vertrauen ich es für zu
animositäten animosität
[Musik]
rampe geht zurück in ein glühbirnen
geschäft
und bleibt sie hat keine gründe
sie sagt nur das was du hast immer auf
mehr wer wird er eigentlich noch mal
frank roßner
mittlerweile glaube ich schon meine
neunte reaction oft worte handle kennt
immer noch nicht die namen von den zehn
leuten ich bin auch ganz schlecht mit
namen auch wenn ich neue leute kennen
lernen sagt die namen und dann direkt
wieder vergessen zack weg
aber mein gehirn ist auch leider halt
nicht da fragen wir jetzt wirklich nur
noch die weitere taste kegelt sauer dass
ich war ich habe gänsehaut ich habe
gänsehaut oh mein gott das war richtig
aebischer moment gerade fragen wlan also
kann lana das doch sagen okay jetzt bin
ich ja heftig gespannt ich bin am arsch
sieht so aus richtig ich bin ja so
gespannt und ich weiß gerade voll
getriggert weil ich die ganze zeit
pausieren also kommt schauen uns das
jetzt mal anders leider zu sagen hat wie
geht es euch heute ziemlich cool
ich hätte wirklich in einer ersten
reaktion stewart länder wie gedacht dass
ich hier so wissen werde vorneweg haben
runter und sharon die regeln gebrochen
erste frage bin gespannt was es negativ
geil geil okay die wahnsinnig ärgert ist
wie beim folio der anode lohnen
millionär und ohne schlaue leute die
schlaue fragen beantworten waren negativ
das ding jetzt positiv
das nicht hast mein herz brachte so
einfach ziehen lassen ein so lange
zittern auf diese antwort positiv fragen
tragen
die sache ist ja auch die haben ja die
ganze zeit geleugnet die haben ja nicht
gesagt von wegen sagen wir nicht müsst
ihr wohl aller fragen nein aber die
ganze zeit gesagt nein seit die bescheid
warum beschuldigung die ganze woche hat
hier die ganze zeit auf uns rum
es war alles zurecht aber francesca wenn
du das noch mal hin ab unter die dusche
das kostet ich finds trotzdem plötzlich
ja ich finde es nicht so lustig klar ich
meine die sind in dieser tv-show und ob
jetzt 3000 euro fair oder nicht aber
keine ahnung was das ist ja alles auch
nur unterhaltung aber trotzdem einfach
rum lügen da neuen leuten gegenüber also
freunden mit denen du weißt fand oder
von denen du weißt du noch länger mit
ihnen da auf dieser insel ist finde ich
einfach irgendwie für mich gehört sich
nicht
aber das ist nur meine meinung meine
lieben freunde das ist auch noch meine
reaktion hierauf diese serie wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann das gerne einen
daumen hoch unter dem ihr da schreibt
immer und in die kommentare was sie
denkt was als nächstes passieren wird
ich hab da so gehört das vielleicht neue
leute auf die insel kommen wollte ihn
der nächste reaktion dann gebt dem video
auf jeden fall den daumen hoch
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt hier
auch schon im auto meiner lieben freunde
wenn ihr meinen kanal noch nicht
abonniert haben sollte dann kriegt man
ganz schnell auf dieses mal hier drauf
ist kostenlos und dem verpasst dadurch
keine videos mehr und wenn ihr schon
aber deshalb blickt man auf die glocke
damit kommt nämlich eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen könnt direkt mit dabei
sein und hier ist ein anderes video
verlinkt es ging hat auf dem zweiten
also etwas gerne